i want to solve ai i want to unlock the
mysteries of intelligence in the
universe we're going to build a
superhuman driving agent for the sake of
building a superhuman driving agent but
if we build something that can
generically learn problems by watching
humans solve them
you can solve a whole lot more than
driving george hotz the hacker slash
entrepreneur who as a teenager became
famous as the first person to jailbreak
the iphone and then the playstation 3 is
in a race to build the world's first
fully self-driving car system hotz's
company comma ai which has raised 8.1
million dollars is competing against
giants like google offshoot waymo amazon
owned zoox and gm's crews which rely on
custom vehicles with expensive sensor
arrays including lidar to identify
surrounding objects and people and
navigate a predetermined path
comma takes a radically different
approach this is all you need to drive a
car
yeah clap i don't want to be the only
company building this hardware open
pilot's open source come play in this
beautiful ecosystem we're paving the way
for you right maybe one of you out there
its latest product the comma 3 runs on a
smartphone processor and plugs into most
new cars taking over the built-in
steering gas and brake systems comma's
open source software open pilot uses
artificial intelligence to predict where
a human would drive in real time now we
can jail make driving chill
self-driving cars are just the beginning
of what all of this technology can allow
i want robots that clean my house and
cook me food right it's the same tech
hot says his better financed competitors
have misled the public with hype about
what their products can do and on what
timetable i think that this self-driving
space is incredibly sad like it went
from companies aren't profitable to
companies don't have revenue to
companies don't have users
so george the last time that we talked
was january 2020 it was about two months
before the pandemic hit or before the
lockdowns uh and i asked you to predict
what was going to happen in the next two
years and you said we could expect to
see a wave of consolidations these you
know self-driving startups get absorbed
back into the parent company or closures
and we've seen some of that happen
zuke's laid off over 100 people we saw
uber and their self-driving effort
lift also ended theirs do you think
we'll see more things like that start to
happen undoubtedly i'm not sure when we
talked if zooks had been bought by
amazon yet
the nikola founder was indicted like i'm
not going to make a prediction that like
waymo and cruz are going to fold in the
next two years i don't really know but
yeah the smaller ones are going to fault
the smaller ones where it's more of a
scam you saw the uber atg fold into
aurora
this one seems like a hot scam right now
aurora also just got permission to
operate self-driving cars with a driver
monitor in california cruz does have a
permit to operate fully autonomous
vehicles whatever that means at this
point in california so do you think that
any of that matters investors
can't even properly evaluate this space
why could governments possibly the hard
part's not the permit the hard part's
not the hardware the hard part is
completely the software you and tesla
and i believe mobileye have a different
approach can you just explain what the
difference is in your approach us tesla
and mobileye are all building cars that
operate in a similar way to a human
where the intelligence is on the car the
intelligence is not in the cloud what
separates you know you or tesla from a
waymo when a waymo decides where to go
that waymo doesn't individually decide
where to go it's been programmed on maps
to basically follow a line
uh with us and tesla we look at the road
and we decide where to drive the car
this is also what humans do if we can't
solve it with vision we are not solving
ai the goal of comma is to solve a.i a
lot of the criticism that you've gotten
is that you know you can't possibly
perform as well as these systems that
have all these sensors that you know
like lidar let's say that there's a
world in which the costs of lidar come
down dramatically so that it would
actually be an affordable thing that you
could
integrate into your product is that
something that you would do or is that
fundamentally
misaligned with with your vision for
with your vision system i don't think
you need it there is an existence proof
in the case of humans that you can drive
a car with vision
we will drive a car with vision it's
just a question of time doesn't that
make it a much harder problem to solve
though because like let's say you're
driving the snow or whatever if you have
lidar maybe the the car can see you know
there's new technologies out that say
they can see hundreds of yards ahead
whereas a human wouldn't be able to so
does that limit your sort of short run
development do you think at all no most
human accidents are not caused by
failures of the human perception system
distraction reaction time just like kind
of like cognitive overload right i
remember when i started driving even
relatively simple driving scenarios
would kind of put me in a cognitive
overload state i think everyone
remembers that when they were 17. it's
like that guy's making a turn i'm making
a turn is it me is it him
so it's that that causes accidents a lot
of times for humans can you just talk
about how your vision system works in
contrast to a system that like is lane
tracking or that uses radar or other
sensors integrated into it we talked
about using lane lines as kind of the
original sin of comet ai
[Music]
we shouldn't have to use lanes we want
to drive end to end we want to look at
where a human drove and then we want to
mimic that we want to do the same thing
as a human without any reference to
anything like lane lines or cars the
only thing we want to say is imagine
giving a human a picture of a road and
say
where do you drive so end to end it's
about intentionality and planning and
where a human would go not just mapping
different things in the visual field yes
it never asks the question what is this
object it asks the question given this
scene where would a human drive the car
you can imagine scenarios have you ever
been in a scenario where it's like a
construction zone and like there's like
a line in the middle of the road and
it's painted and it's kind of a little
bit confusing which to follow especially
if you're using any kind of hand coded
detect the lanes policy
uh
our car without the use of lane lines
does much better in scenarios like that
also in scenarios of say
suburban streets which don't have any
lane markers at all it will now stay to
the right and it will move a little
around for park cars so for example lane
changes there's nothing in the car that
where we coded anything about how to do
a lane change
all we did was labeled again
automatically in the ground truth where
humans made lane changes and said this
is a lane change right nothing special
about the word lane change we could have
called it this was a black so can you
just explain specifically how is that
different than what tesla's doing tesla
has a hand coded layer between
perception and planning
tesla has a layer where they're
outputting an abstracted human
understandable feature space from the
cameras we're not
so when we train we train straight from
pictures to plan when tesla trains they
train from pictures to labels and then
have this quasi-hand-coded thing which
goes from labels to plan
so you have no hand coding at this point
there's still a little hand coded but
not really we can now detect where
you're supposed to stop for a red light
or a stop sign and we don't do this by
ever coding in a red light or a stop
sign we do this by asking where did
humans stop and stay stopped for a while
and so when the machine looks at that
scene is there any way to see what it's
seeing or like know what how it's
arriving at that decision we can ask at
that question but why do we care
the question is not
like who cares if it stopped because it
saw the stop sign or it stopped because
it saw the word stop on the road the
only question we care about answering is
how many stop signs did you successfully
stop at
i don't care how you came up with the
answer i care that you got the right
answer and so does this make it
more difficult if you want to let's say
go back in and understand how your
system made a decision right so tesla
has that layer i imagine so that they
can go and be like well we didn't detect
this fire hydrant or whatever it is what
i find funny about this
is after a car accident
you can ask the driver what happened
and
the driver is not
accessing their perception states at
that time to figure out what happened
they're actually usually making up a
story
a lot of times they're usually making up
a story to make them look better right
he came out of nowhere man right and
listen to drivers talk about this if you
really want to figure out what happened
in a car accident dashcam footage is
incredible
if you have dashcam footage from both
cars you can figure out what happened
much better than asking the humans
so why should deep learning systems be
any different if you want to figure out
why the car made a decision there is no
why just look at what the car did
and then you can say okay well
we can figure out why it did that by
reasoning about the system holistically
not explicitly saying well there was a
lane there and it's not a good way to do
it you consider tesla like the ios you
know it's the it's the iphone of the
self-driving world you want to be the
android you want to be the other half of
that market and work with all these
different hardware manufacturers how
does openpilot compare to autopilot
tesla's offering at this point we're
trying to make driving chill
maybe tesla's slogan is look at this
crazy feature and one of the things that
is like that is is like right turns in
an intersection right
but you would sort of look forward to
this point being where we would start to
see whole commutes and you know sort of
longer trips that you know your system
could take over isn't that a big part of
commuting and like why why is that a
problem that you haven't solved yet you
may be able to get to an arbitrary level
faster using hand coded stuff we aren't
targeting
doing right turns or doing whole
commutes say okay maybe we'll talk about
the lowest abstraction level if you're
talking about something that hand
detects a car right like i'm looking for
tail lights and i'm looking for wheels
right you're working at like a really
low level
nobody would advocate that anymore but
by the way back in 2008 this was how
people advocated for computer vision
it's like if you want to detect a car
well we'll detect the wheel we'll detect
the light we'll detect the hood nobody
does that anymore right so nobody works
at this level they work at this level
which is like a little bit higher up
where it's like we're going to put a box
around the car
and it's almost like they didn't learn
that lesson we take that lesson and go
even a level up we're like we're just
going to build something that
drives
and then
we're going to build we're going to
solve it in a holistic way not in a
piece by piece sort of way so you're
saying that you're not going to
specifically code for let's say making a
right turn yeah you're going to iterate
the system so like let's say now it's
like a teenager or maybe it's like a
five-year-old and then once it gets to
the to be a teenager then it'll make a
right turn when
when that of evolution happens the
overall evolution yes is that any
different like writing that type of code
for this end-to-end holistic system
versus an iterative you know or sort of
a step function type system yes and i'll
phrase this a little differently if you
asked me to code a chess engine and i
had two hours i'm not going to build an
end-to-end chess engine i'm going to
build some you know hand-coded crap with
some very basic you know board
evaluation function and some very basic
search and i could write you a chess
engine i could write a chess engine in
two hours that can beat me at chess
but
i couldn't write a chess engine in two
hours that's superhuman and in fact
there's no path from the chess engine
that i wrote in two hours to one that's
superhuman the one that superhuman
requires a radically new architecture
i wouldn't build anything about pawns
and rooks because i'm not a chess expert
i don't know how to code that board
evaluation function but i do know
how to code the win and the lose state
in chess i can code that and i can code
that perfectly
so i would build something that learns
how to play chess by playing millions of
games against itself and i'm confident
if you gave me a month i could build a
chess engine that beats magnus carlsen
so it's the same thing with driving if
you want to see amazing results tomorrow
don't build any end-to-end stuff but if
you want to solve the problem over a
10-year time horizon
build this and from a business
perspective you know elon musk is sort
of famous for over promising uh or you
know his timelines like i think the
first time he said that they were going
to have full self driving within the
year was maybe three years ago do you
think that that feeds back into the way
that they are approaching this problem
where they have to you know sort of meet
these individual intermediate deadlines
and you're you don't yes
i do um i think that from what i heard
from the autopilot team one of their
main goals was to get elon's commute to
happen without a disengagement
hence the right turns yes i don't think
this is a good approach i don't care if
we solve self-driving cars in one year
or 10 years
or 20 years
we want to do it in the
correct way and in the correct way
that's going to scale to way more than
self-driving cars if we build something
that references cars and lane lines
things only probably useful for driving
but if we build something that can
generically learn problems by watching
humans solve them
we can solve a whole lot more than
driving with the same code in the same
way alpha zero didn't just solve chess
but it also solved go and shogi with the
exact same code base so the way that you
sort of put together most of your model
is through big data right so you have a
lot of people that are out driving with
commas they give you data and then you
use that to train the vision system and
you have far fewer users than tesla's
right there's hundreds of thousands of
teslas out there so how are you
competing with them in terms of having
that amount of data to to train your
models on so we have 10 million miles of
driving data sitting right over there
and 10 million uh it's 10 million
minutes a 10 million minutes is about 20
years of solid driving
this has to be enough and the reason i
know this is enough is
20 year olds can drive cars
right so
remember that it's not just learning the
driving problem it's also learning
vision entirely humans take a lot of
time to learn vision you're like well
humans actually learn to drive in like
two years and they do
but humans have to learn all of vision
and all of color and all of shape and
physics and but we have 20 years that
should be enough and the data has
empirically shown that we're actually
only training on a million of those 10
million so we could 10x if we start to
see improvement but
uh
it's it's been diminishing returns ever
since like 400 000. and then for the
edge cases i guess my my main question
is if you're taking this route don't you
need sort of a pretty much a general ai
like an ai that's capable of reasoning
like a human because let's say that you
know a ball
uh comes across the road right and a
human would know okay there's maybe a
little kid coming after that ball right
but a machine would not know that unless
it sort of has a general
knowledge base of course it would how
many times in its data set has it seen
kids run after balls
and if it hasn't seen enough we need
more data so okay so it's ultimately a
data problem of course it's a data
problem for humans right humans only
know that kids run after balls because
they've seen it at some point in their
life
it's all a data problem to believe that
humans have any sort of general
reasoning i'm not sure how true that is
so you don't think that there's a
distinction in terms of higher level
cognitive reasoning in humans that you'd
have to reproduce for this type of
system no especially not for driving
humans largely drive on autopilot right
when you think about the kid in the ball
it's instinctive it's not like it's not
like using the long human reasoning
pathway i mean even the long human
reasoning pathway like you might use for
chess or go yes that looks a little bit
different from largely feed forward
neural networks it looks more like
search
but we're pretty good at this too
again like we're here to solve ai we're
not here to write hacks in general the
long-term vision that you have like is
this the right vehicle for what you want
to do with solving ai still seems pretty
right it's interesting to think about
now what happens also after we solve
self-driving cars
i think that
home robotics is harder
cleaning and cooking are harder than
driving because there's a million
correct ways to chop an onion there's
only kind of one correct way to drive
down a highway
there's always a joke about things being
ai complete and it's like if you can
solve this task um it is uh ai complete
meaning you can't solve this task
without solving agi i do not believe
driving is ai complete agi being
artificial general intelligence so
basically like you can recreate a human
yes agi is a program that can do
everything a human capable of doing
we define humans as having general
intelligence whether that's true or not
it's a definition
so
i do not believe that driving is ai
complete i believe that we can solve
driving in such a way that we still
can't solve cooking and cleaning
now
from this perspective it seems like if
we solve cooking and cleaning it might
be
agi but
history has told you to bet against that
over and over again and as that goal
post starts to get closer you realize oh
no there's actually a whole lot more to
it
wow we built robots that cook and clean
really well but there's still a whole
lot more to what it means to be a human
and what historically are you talking
about in terms of people thinking it
needs to have general intelligence but
it doesn't chess
1995 chess
ai complete the only way you're ever
going to beat human grandmasters to
chess is by solving ai
this turned out to not be true five
years later
there's no way you're ever going to be
able to like detect chairs and images
until you've solved ai this was wrong 10
years later there's no way you're ever
going to be able to solve go without
solving ai that was wrong five years
later people say this about driving
watch we'll do it without solving ai and
so ultimately the reason that you're
taking the approach that you're taking
more than even for the self-driving
application is that it will be useful
moving towards agi and all these other
applications like cooking and cleaning
yes and i also do believe that it is the
fastest way to get to superhuman
self-driving cars though that's an
empirical claim that i may be wrong
about and what other applications can
you foresee for for this like what's
what's your talked about cooking and
cleaning robots after cars is there
anything else that you know you would
you would see as like one of the the
first applications beyond self-driving
cars
building robots autonomous tractors true
autonomous farming
everything you can imagine being done by
kind of um
maybe the word is day laborers do you
have an idea of where you think the line
is where an agi is actually necessary
there are some fundamental things to
talk about where you can say that like
for example humans have about 20 paid a
flops of compute
if you want 20 pedaflops now you need an
entire rack of google tpu v3s
you can get a human's worth of compute
but it costs millions of dollars and it
costs thousands and thousands of dollars
per hour for the power to run it
maybe we can say
in like 2038 you'll be able to buy a
human's worth of compute for a thousand
bucks so you don't think that there's a
fundamental difference between let's say
a human and a bird in terms of like you
know we talk about in raw compute right
but cognition is generally thought of as
you know sort of a higher level
like we don't it doesn't flow directly
from the structure that creates it right
so do you disagree with that the only
difference between humans and birds is
humans think they're special
that's the flipping answer but no i
don't i think intelligence is continuous
on a spectrum for you to posit a step
function like like major step
to get from like the animals to humans
that seems like the thing that requires
a justification and i've never seen a
good justification for that maybe there
are paradigms of learning
that you can make kind of a qualitative
distinction on the first paradigm of
learning is genetic the only way
bacteria learn is by evolution
the second paradigm of learning is like
a
nematode worm learns and then you get
into the mammals which all share this
kind of third paradigm of learning you
learn from your parents you learn from
society you learn from culture
maybe i'll posit a three and a half with
writing
because we can learn from humans 2000
years ago without them actually being
here and then fourth paradigm is like i
know kung fu so uh computers are fourth
paradigm learners maybe that is a real
distinction and i think a lot of this is
what makes people uncomfortable with
artificial intelligence or you know
black box algorithms in general right is
that we can't see into it to know how
it's making a decision necessarily right
do you find that uncomfortable i heard a
good quote people complaining about
billionaires wasting money going to
space are going to be shocked when they
find out how much money governments
waste
people who are concerned about machines
being black boxes are going to be
shocked when they find out about humans
maybe i ask those people whether the old
people telling people what to think
really had their best interests in mind
or not this also is sort of a
fundamental discomfort that people have
with distributed systems right because
you can't necessarily control them i
think this is almost a philosophical
distinction
between
you know google's way of viewing the
world it's like you know we're the cloud
we own everything and like no you've got
to decentralize it has this inherent
advantage of trust
everybody can look at the distributed
decentralized system
and trust it's also true with open pilot
if you want to decide how much to trust
your open pilot openpilot is open source
code you can read it you can modify it
if you want to decide how much to trust
your waymo well do you trust google do
you trust their organizational uh
structure that you have no insight into
and so how do you think that distributed
systems uh you know bitcoin included or
crypto but other things as well how are
they able to offer more value to
individuals than the existing structures
the decentralized software is only so
good bitcoin network can only process a
small number of transactions per second
visa can process a lot more visa is
technically better than bitcoin but in
the long run this flips bitcoin gets
better every year and visa gets worse
every year
whenever visa blocks payments to
at first it's just you know julian
assange and then it's
sex workers and then it's
right-wing people and then it's whoever
you know the new the new
people
visa you know decides to go after so
visa gets worse
more censored
and like more scummy kind of every year
they're like how can we extract more
value from these people how can we raise
the apr in this weird clause that
nobody's ever going to read in the
contract another beautiful thing that i
love about crypto is forks you can't
deploy a decentralized exchange to
ethereum and take
30 fees apple takes 30 fees in the app
store because if you took 30 fees that's
enough to fork
now if you take 3
fees
maybe not but it forces a much more sane
dynamic
this is free exit in countries too it's
the same basic idea if you have
you know you can't sustain tax rates
that are insanely high because people
will leave right and if you could fork
the country people would leave even
sooner
this is
a great thing about it's very easy to
make more digital land
i'm hoping that we're going to see a
decade of decentralization and do you
see the risk of that you know being
slower or not happening as mostly
political given that you know i think
polarization and this group wants to ban
these people and this group wants to ban
these people and they all rely on a sort
of central authority that is capable of
doing that right you hear people like
elizabeth warren and other politicians
now
saying that we need to ban or regulate
crypto really heavily for this reason
right
because they don't know where the
payments are going right it could be
buying guns it could be buying drugs you
never know
um so do you see that as a significant
risk this is why i don't do politics it
all happens on the wrong time scale
it happens on this small
time scale they all act like the world
is falling and then some new
administration takes power or some new
country gains prominence
uh and this has happened throughout
history
so no in the
long march of technology technology wins
seems like governments have been equally
shitty throughout all of history but
when you look at technology it's very
rare that technology declines
whereas governments and corporations
fail all the time so what do i
fundamentally trust more
not organizations of people but
technology
the bitcoin software the ethereum
software the blockchain software will
improve year over year slowly
these organizations some will rise some
will decline
but someday the software will beat them
all and do you think that these systems
that are distributed like you know
bitcoin one of the promises of it is
that
it can't be regulated to a certain level
right i mean we're finding out that
there are you know it's not quite as
anonymous as people think it is but
fundamentally do you think that it's
possible to build systems that are not
touchable by existing power structures
no
i think power structures will always
find ways
i think that how power structures come
to prominence is usually by offering
something
the things that they will be able to
offer will diminish with time as
technology gets better
you can imagine one of the things that
power structures fundamentally offer you
is protection from violence i wouldn't
need that if i had a arm-based force
field that could fend off bullets and
knives and everything right the need for
the power structure would decrease so no
i don't think it's that power structures
can't fundamentally regulate these
things i think it's that the way power
structures gain power and the way not
just governments but also corporations
gain
power is by offering people value
and as the value they can offer
decreases
their ability to rise in the first place
decreases
why do you think that this the 2020s are
going to be fundamentally different and
we're going to finally get to this
decentralized
ideal
i can see
comfortably by the end of the decade
crypto money technology which is
actually technically capable of
replacing visa
this is not true in 2020 it certainly
was not true in 2010 and krypto didn't
even exist in 2000. but by 2030 i could
see it getting to the point where even
extrapolating growth of payment networks
crypto can actually
exceed the technical capacity required
i've also seen a general decline in a
lot of organizational structures
so
one goes up one goes down lines cross at
some point i'm hoping for this decade
how do you see this playing out on the
ground right has is comma going to
change do you think that the tech
industry will change in a fundamental
way i think one of the biggest changes
is
startups with this thing mark zuckerberg
dropping out of college coming out to
silicon valley was this narrative and
he was kind of one of the first people
to do it
today if you drop out of harvard move to
silicon valley and raise money from
institutional investors you are not a
maverick you are a copycat and it is
fundamentally a different type of person
who does the former and does the latter
it needs to be a new type of thing it
needs to be who actually is breaking the
mold it isn't moving to silicon valley
valley and taking money from
institutional investors that is the
power structure that is not disruption
what does actual disruption look like
uber and lyft are massively more
expensive than they ever have been do
you think that's a function of what
we're just talking about where you know
the bills come due and they've been
floating on all this vc money for so
long um is it the pandemic is it a
combination of both something like
uber's interesting people 10 years ago
would talk about how
uber shouldn't be this middle man
they're just a middleman extracting
profits
actually 10 years ago the opposite was
true uber was paying out the drivers
more than the riders were paying there
was no way to possibly compete with them
but as that starts to shift and the more
that starts to shift
the better the peer-to-peer
decentralized uber looks what do you
think about you know the experiments
that we've done on like a universal
basic income
or uh you know basically giving people
free money right uh how do you think
that that is going to play into how
things evolve from here where's this
free money coming from who has the
authority to give free money
that's the interesting question right
if you have two [ __ ] coins and in one
[ __ ] coin the owners have access to the
mint function and just arbitrarily mint
more whenever they feel like it and you
have another [ __ ] coin where the owners
uh transferred ownership to the zero
address so nobody can call mint
well the value of these coins is
probably gonna go like this
but there certainly are tokens like that
and they don't gain adoption people
don't like that why do those guys have
access to the mint function and not me i
don't feel that good about this tell me
the mint function in bitcoin is like a
hash rate competition and everybody can
participate and hear the rules i feel
better about that yeah right that's a
currency that i believe in more for the
long term than the currency where it's
arbitrary and guys are like ah but he
really needs it mint him some coin
all right
so the fact that like in a decentralized
network where people aren't operating at
the behest of some centralized authority
they choose not to buy coins that have
unlimited printing
do you think that that's analogous to
the dollar i love competition i love
seeing competition i love seeing
competition for everything competition
for money competition for televisions
competition for self-driving systems and
competition for uh governments all that
competition's great
[Music]